LAURA TERRY-GREEN: My
name is Laura Terry-Green,
and it gives me great pleasure
to introduce Paula Madison.
I had the privilege of
serving as her college intern
at NBC Universal, so it's an
honor to have her here today.
Paula currently serves
as the chairman and CEO
of Madison Media Management, a
Los Angeles based global media
consultancy company.
Paula previously served as
executive vice president
of diversity at NBC
Universal, and vice president
of General Electric,
the then parent company.
Paula is the recipient of
numerous high profile honors
and awards.
And she was the former franchise
owner of the WNBA's Los Angeles
Sparks basketball team.
Paula is the executive producer
of "Finding Samuel Lowe:
from Harlem to China," a
compelling documentary that
chronicles her journey
to discovering more
about her heritage.
Her memoirs, "Finding Samuel
Lowe: China, Jamaica, Harlem,"
were also published
in April of last year.
Paula's journey has been both
extraordinary and compelling.
And we are fortunate to
have her here with us today.
So without further ado, I'd like
to bring up Miss Paula Madison.
[APPLAUSE]
PAULA MADISON: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi!
PAULA MADISON: So
thank you for coming.
I don't know, I
think I'm supposed
to talk to you about the
strange victory of my life,
and have you ask some questions,
and I'll try to answer them.
What I like to do at
the very beginning,
although you saw
video of me, but I
like to do at the
very beginning,
so that we get past
this thing-- which is,
does she look Chinese to you?
So what I like to do
at the very beginning,
I'm going to remove
my glasses, and you
take a look for yourself.
And then stop being
distracted, and pay attention
to what I'm saying.
So here we go.
This is your moment.
OK, there you go.
Now you can answer for
yourself, but pay attention.
So as Laura said, I had
a pretty varied life.
And you saw the
little bit in the clip
there, where my oldest
brother talked about where
we grew up in Harlem.
My mother was the first
person in our family.
Or so I thought.
The first person in our family
to come to the United States.
She came in 1945, under the
Chinese immigration quota.
It's when the Chinese
Exclusion Act was eased.
How many people know about
the Chinese Exclusion Act?
Yeah.
So a lot of folks don't
know that the only nation
on the planet that the United
States has actually passed laws
to keep that particular nation's
citizens from establishing
residency in the United
States, is China.
And beginning in the 1880s,
with some regular frequency,
Congress passed a
series of laws to keep
Chinese people from
being citizens,
and residents of
the United States.
They could come and work.
Yes, so they built the
transcontinental railroad
from the west.
You know that famous
picture in Promontory, Utah?
Which really wasn't
in Promontory,
which says a whole lot.
But when they're driving
in that final stake,
connecting the
east and the west.
There's a lot of
people in that picture
kind of taking credit,
and being really
proud that we got this done.
And not one person in
that photo is Chinese.
When in fact, the majority
of the workers were Chinese.
Many of them were Hakka.
I was explaining to
Laura at lunch today,
my multiculturalism and
my multiracial background,
which I don't know
a lot of people
who don't have some kind
of multiracial background.
But in my case, it seems
to be some surprise at,
black and Chinese?
That's actually very common.
Particularly in the Caribbean.
And particularly throughout
Central and Latin America.
The Chinese people
and Indians who
got to the Caribbean,
which all blended.
Which gives some people
on some of the islands
a so-called exotic look.
Came about because of
the abolition of slavery.
How does that feed in, you ask?
Well in 1838, when the
British abolished slavery
in its territories, the Africans
who were no longer enslaved
said, for love or money,
we're not cutting anymore
sugar cane for you.
So they wouldn't work.
For you.
And so the owners of
the sugar plantations
got the next cheapest labor.
They brought indentured
workers from India and China.
And the first Chinese
arrived in Jamaica in 1854.
Now, they didn't generally
let them bring their women,
nor their families.
So who could resist the
beauty of Jamaican women?
Certainly not my grandfather.
So my grandfather actually
had two African Jamaican women
with whom he had children.
And my mother was
separated from her father
when she was three years old.
The picture of the
woman who you saw,
who looked very-- There were
two photos, side by side.
One looked like a kind
of Chinese woman, in
and the other one
was a black man.
Those are my parents.
I became very, very, very
aware as a little girl
about racial distinctions.
Differences.
And I became very,
very, very aware,
because my mother, who had
been taken from her father
when she was three years
old, and never saw him again.
This is how the break
in my family happened.
My mother, when I was born--
so I was the last child,
and I was the only girl.
So the first two were
boys, who were welcomed.
Why would you think
they'd be welcomed?
Chinese culture.
Chinese culture,
boys, love boys.
Girls, not so much.
That would be why in some
parts of the country,
in certain eras of history, you
would see whites with strollers
with little Chinese girls.
Because the Chinese girls
were given up for adoption.
They weren't really wanted.
My mother didn't give
me up for adoption, no.
But my mother's hair
was down to here.
My mother recoiled from my hair.
Like, oh my god, what am
I going to do with that?
What was interesting was, when
my mother was three years old,
her mother-- While she
kept her from being
raised with her Chinese father,
her mother didn't want her.
Because she was mixed race.
And there was a certain
amount of shame associated
with that in Jamaica.
Particularly when you're not
with your Chinese family.
So my grandmother, who I
only met once in my life,
pretty much deposited my
mother with her grandmother.
And my mother said every day,
her grandmother would call her,
you half Chinee wretch.
That was, I guess,
her affectionate name
for her granddaughter.
And so my mother grew
up between cultures.
She looked Chinese, was being
raised by African Jamaicans,
and nobody wanted her.
Except her Chinese father,
who could not find her.
When I was a little
girl, my mother
who had grown up in this kind
of an environment, looked at me.
The last child
and the only girl.
And had no idea what
to do with my hair.
Now I don't know
that I necessarily
want to define this whole
conversation around hair,
but here's how it starts.
Most little black girls
had the experience
of sitting either on
their mother's lap,
or between their
mother's legs, and having
their hair combed and braided.
I never had that experience
till I was six years old.
Not that I walked around with
this wild hair, no, no, no.
But my mother bussed me
upstairs to a nice lady
from North Carolina, who combed
my hair until I was about six.
And I think that kind of
created an interesting
but a little bit
strained relationship
between me and my mother.
Because, just as
my mother didn't
have a woman who looked like
her to identify with, right?
I grew up in Harlem,
with my mother,
oh absolutely in the house.
But the identification,
the multiracial-ism
in our household made
things kind of interesting.
So when I said
earlier that I was
very aware of
racial distinctions
from a very early
age, and you heard
that I ended up becoming the
Chief Diversity Officer for NBC
Universal-- before that I had
a long and storied journalism
career.
I ran the news department
for NBC4 in New York City.
There's so many--
I'm 63 years old.
There's so many firsts
that I could tell you,
but you'd be bored.
And I'm bored by
even-- What I can
say to you is that once I did
all those kinds of things,
I had a boss who said,
well don't retire early.
Stay on.
I want you to run
diversity at NBC Universal.
And I was like oh, no.
No, no.
Not going to do it.
Because I'm not good
at being a consultant.
I'm not good at telling people,
I think you should do this.
But then they ignore you.
Which in many instances
is what happens
when you are leading diversity.
Rarely does a diversity
person report to the CEO.
But in my case, because I'm
somewhat strange and demanding,
unless I reported to the
CEO, we're not even talking.
So I reported to the CEO.
But I still said no.
And about two weeks
before that, my family--
And nobody in my
company knew this,
because it was not
their business.
We were independently wealthy.
Why do you work?
Why not.
So I had planned
to retire early.
And an individual
approached my family
about investing in the
Los Angeles Sparks.
The WNBA team.
And I was like no,
we like basketball,
we watch basketball.
But that's a business, that
I don't know that business.
And my brothers didn't
know that business.
But in a short amount of
time, like a week later.
This radio personality
by the name of Don Imus
referred to the Rutgers
Women's Basketball team
as nappy headed-- I
won't say the word.
Starts with an H, not an N.
It actually starts with a W,
but you know in street parlance.
All right, you're right.
So after that happened, I
was moved to do two things.
One, I decided not
to retire early.
Because I was really mad.
And two, I went to the little
kids in my family, and said,
hey, you guys want to
own a basketball team?
Yeah!
Well, how about we
buy the LA Sparks?
Yeah!
And that's how we
got into basketball.
It's probably the worst
emotional decision I ever made.
Not because I didn't enjoy
it, and not because I
didn't love basketball.
Not because I didn't
love our team.
Because of all that I did.
But when you have a
team, and although we
had the only television
contract in the league.
Local television
Although we had the highest
attendance in the league,
you just can't make a
WNBA team profitable.
It's a whole
different conversation
So when you have a business
that's not profitable,
what is it?
It's called a hobby.
So I sold the team
to Magic Johnson.
But what it did help me do, was
when I realized that there are
actually people
walking the planet who
feel very comfortable
saying what Don Imus said--
Not just in a room, you know?
But it was broadcast
to millions.
Well I thought that I should
make him pay for that.
I thought that I should make
somebody learn from that,
and so I decided to stay on.
I decided to not retire.
I actually had somebody asked
me once, well, you know,
did working in television
and in news and all
that, prepare you for being
the Chief Diversity Officer?
And I was like, no, no.
Having my mother look
the way my mother looked
as a single parent,
growing up in Harlem,
that's what prepared me.
We used to hang out-- I went to
Catholic school, but-- Not but.
I went to Catholic school
and, it was in the days
where everybody just
hung out all the time.
You played, you
played in the park,
you just double
dutch, ringolevio,
we just played New
York City street games.
And everything would be fine
and cool, and not an issue,
until my mother
would come outside.
Oh look, I'm outside,
it's summertime.
Paula!
Come in for dinner!
And depending upon who
I was playing with,
if that person already knew
my family, and knew my mother,
it would be cool.
OK, I'm going to go
and eat, I'll be back.
But if the person wasn't
familiar with what
he or she was looking at,
and usually it was a she.
It would be like, who's that?
Response, that's my mother.
Next statement could either
be, oh, then we're cool.
Sometimes the statement would
be, that is not your mother.
Derogatory term used to
describe Chinese people.
What's the reasonable response?
You punch them in the face!
[LAUGHTER]
That was my reasonable response.
So when I was 9
10, 11 years old,
this is kind-- I don't
even think I took the time
to ask, what did you say?
Because at that point, you're
kind of like an amoeba.
You're just responsive.
Press that.
So somebody would say
that, and-- And by the way
my mother was not
what one would think
would you know-- that sort
of retiring Chinese woman.
My mother didn't
grow up like that.
I have one anecdote to tell you.
And I'm going to get to
the point of all of this.
My one anecdote is that, when
my brother, my oldest brother
was about 13 years old,
he got into a fight
with a kid who lived
like four blocks away.
And this kid came
from a large family.
And we had no other
relatives around.
It was my mother and
her three children.
And this kid and my brother
got into a fight at the gym.
And my brother beat him up.
They were the same
age, same size.
In finality, the guy ran
and left his sneakers.
And those being
the spoils of war,
my brother picked up the
sneakers and brought them home.
He was never going to wear them.
But you know, we was
probably going to--
So before all that could happen.
In our neighborhood, we
had neighborhood runners.
These are people who, they're
announcing something big
is happening.
So we had a first
floor apartment,
and everybody's doors
were always open.
So you could hear this kid
running down the street.
Miss Nell!
This man's coming,
he's going to come.
He's coming, he's
going to beat up Elric.
So here is my mother.
My mother grabbed
the meat cleaver.
There was not a blade in my
house that was not sharp.
My mother picked up
the meat cleaver.
She said to my oldest
brother, Elric, get the bat.
That was a baseball bat.
She said Howard,
get the handcuffs.
Those were handcuffs from, I
think, the First World War.
They were iron, and
they were really heavy.
And if you held one side and
you swung it around like a bola,
you would kill someone.
So Howard had the handcuffs.
Paula, bring the cat.
So we had a cat, Frisky.
And Frisky was very kind and
gentle, until you tossed her.
And then Frisky's
claws would just--
And she would not stop clawing.
So, Paula, bring the cat.
So I brought the cat.
So we all go outside.
And this man who's more
than six feet tall,
with four of his sons,
they come down the street.
And my mother is on the stoop.
You know the stoop.
From the tenement.
And she's like this.
Oh, it would be on
the other side, sorry.
Because she was right handed.
So my mother is leaning,
and she's like this.
And a gentleman walks
up with his sons,
and he says to his
son, is that the kid?
Kid goes yeah.
And he says-- And before
anything else could happen,
my mother was at his throat.
Holding it, and had the meat
cleaver against his jugular.
Now the people in
my neighborhood,
they knew Miss Nell.
And they knew she was
not to be messed with.
My mother taught me
as a little girl,
that if you get
into a fight, don't
stop until the other
person can't get up.
Now you would think, what?
Who tells their
child-- Single mother.
In Harlem.
And we were the only
people in our neighborhood
who came from what today is
referred to as a broken family.
Everybody else back then,
the mother and father
lived in the home.
We were the only ones
who, that wasn't the case.
Plus our mother looked
like-- who is that?
What is she doing here?
My mother comes from, on
the Chinese side, is Hakka.
And Hakka women are
the only women in China
who culturally never
bound their feet.
The culture of Hakka
people is that the women
didn't bind their feet.
Do you know what foot
binding is supposed to mean?
It's beauty.
Tiny feet.
So they break your feet
when you're little,
and they wrap them
and bind them.
And if your feet are
stumps, you can't walk.
Now the only way that
you can actually survive,
is if you're wealthy enough
to have someone carry you.
So foot binding was a
sign of beauty and wealth.
Hakka women have always
been industrious.
Hakka means, I guess in a nice
way, I would say guest people.
They started out
in northern China.
And through wars and
dislocation and whatever,
they ended up moving down and
down and down into the farthest
part of China.
Which is the South Easternmost
province, Guangdong province.
And everywhere the Hakka people
went, they went in a band.
They'd mix with
the local people,
but they'd build
their houses, and then
build walls around them.
They'd build their villages,
because they were always
at war.
So Hakka women,
are the only women
who didn't bind their feet.
And they fought
alongside Hakka men.
So that's one side.
The other side is Jamaica.
More than 94% of the people in
Jamaica are Akan, or Ashanti.
Present day Ghana.
And there are people
culturally in Jamaica,
who are known as the Maroons.
It's a variation of the
Spanish word Cimarrones,
which means the wild ones.
So these Maroons,
were the people
who would come down
from the mountains.
They'd attack the slave owners.
Oh, and of course kill them.
And they'd kill any slaves
who wouldn't join them.
So after a period of time,
the governor of the island
was told by the King
of England, you've
got to do a treaty
with these people.
make them stop killing us.
And so they signed the treaty.
And the Maroons
said, OK, we promise.
We won't kill you guys anymore.
In exchange for that,
they were given land
in the hills of Jamaica.
And the treaty
lasted about a year,
and then they started
killing them again.
And that is why the British
stopped bringing slaves
to Jamaica to be broken in.
Because it didn't work.
And the Jamaicans are generally
known as a pretty surly group.
We are, I guess
prideful, and pugnacious.
Yeah, I think so.
So the two most famous Maroons
who you would be familiar with,
are probably Bob Marley,
and Marcus Garvey.
And that would be
why, by the way,
the United States did
not give Jamaicans
immigration rights for many
years into this country.
They suspended them.
Because the Jamaicans
are a very unruly people.
Yay for us.
So having said that.
On both sides of my
mother's lineage,
she comes from a warrior group.
So the fighting, and teaching
her children to fight,
was natural.
But what also would
happen would be,
we talked about race and
multiculturalism all the time.
So given how my
mother looked, right?
This man walked up on
her son, and he thought
it was all going to be OK.
My mother held him here had
the meat cleaver at his neck,
and said, what are
you doing here?
And I remember it
like it was yesterday.
And this man, he was
like-- She said, talk.
Why are you here?
And he said, I came to
get my son's sneakers.
And she said, no you didn't.
You thought you were
going to hurt my son.
Then she said, I'll
kill you, right
in front of your children.
Even I-- I was like, Whoa, ma.
Not that I said anything out
loud, because I never-- no.
Because when Nell was in
that, all you wanted to do
was breathe gently.
So it ultimately ended with
her telling him to leave,
and he did.
My brother gave
back the sneakers.
But what it did, was
established reputation.
It cemented my
mother's reputation.
My mother was known
for, that's not a woman
who you want to mess with.
Counter to, I think, the
stereotype that a lot of people
had about Chinese people.
And certainly Chinese
people in Harlem.
And there were very many.
This is truly not stereotypical,
but most of the time
when we encountered
Chinese people,
they owned a Chinese laundry, or
they had a Chinese restaurant.
And that was pretty much it.
What my mother made
certain of was,
because I think she
was treated the way
she was treated when
she was a child.
If you asked my
mother, what are you?
She would say, I'm Jamaican.
Yeah but.
And she'd say, well, now
depending upon the era,
she'd say I'm colored, or
I'm negro, or I'm black.
Why?
Because my mother identified
with her children.
Which is what no
one did for her.
My mother made us into a tribe,
and the tribe she made us into
was this tribe.
I forgot, one other anecdote.
When I was in third grade,
I came home from school.
Catholic school.
I had my little report card.
I handed to my mother.
I was always the A student.
Always the A student.
I didn't know how not
to be an A student.
I hand her my report card, she
looks at me, and leaned in.
Not Cheryl Sandberg
leaning in, by the way.
She leaned into my
face, and she said,
I did not come to
this country for you
to get a B. Changes
your whole life.
Generally, children of
immigrants totally get that.
The expectation
for my mother, was,
regardless of how
she looked, whatever
her racial presentation was.
Her expectations
for her children
had nothing to do
with traditionally
how we were expected to perform.
Because among the things that
my mother told us, was that,
children perform
frequently to the level
that adults expect
them to perform.
So my mother had only gone
as far as second form.
And my mother taught
us how to read
when we were three years old.
Using what?
The New York Herald
Tribune newspaper.
Are you supposed
to teach kids how
to read at three years old
with a daily newspaper?
That's what my
mother had to read.
Consequently that's
what we had to read.
My mother had every expectation
that she came to the United
States, and it was
our responsibility
to fulfill her dream.
And what was her dream?
Children of immigrants?
Children of immigrants,
from the South to the North,
what's the dream?
To be wealthy.
To be wealthy!
To take advantage of what's
offered in this country.
The streets are paved with gold.
I mean, when you're
living in another country,
sometimes these things
don't seem so far fetched.
When you're living
in another country,
and you hear that the
child of so-and-so
grew up to run Standard Oil.
Or the child of so-and-so
grew up to become President.
owned the railroad.
These things actually
happened in the United States
of America.
So why would an immigrant
think that it couldn't
happen for her children?
So my mother's
insistence was, nobody
can take away your education.
And I came to this country
for you to be wealthy.
You grow up to be
wealthy, or I'm
going to pull your
tongue out of your head.
Yes mommy.
So the level of expectation--
we became independently
wealthy at a pretty early age.
Because what she
said was, no one
can take your education away.
And oh by the way.
If someone tries to
prevent you from achieving
what you need to
achieve, you have
to do what I tell you to do.
And in her mind, my
mother's motto was--
and I can't bang on my
chest, because I-- Oh I can,
because the microphone.
My mother said, they'd
have to kill me first.
So that's how we grew up.
We're either going
to get it done,
and you get out of
my way, or you're
going to have to kill me first.
So with all of that--
With all of that,
I ended up with a
great sensitivity
to racial distinctions.
I grew up understanding
how and why coming
from two sides of my family.
There are two
sides of my family,
my lineage, where there were
lynchings in the United States,
of my people.
On the black side, absolutely.
And on the Chinese side.
And many people in
this country do not
know the Chinese
people were lynched.
The miscegenation laws, which
were passed in this country.
Most people think it
was to keep the blacks
and whites from mixing.
Well it was.
But it was also used to
keep the Chinese railroad
workers, and other
labor positions,
from mixing with
Caucasian women.
And here in California, what
we don't have in California
is what we have
in the Caribbean.
You know, my grandfather had
three women who he had children
by in Jamaica.
Two African Jamaican, and
one was a Chinese bride
that his parents sent
from China, sight unseen,
for him to marry.
And obedient son that
he was, he married.
And they had it so my
grandfather's total offspring,
there were eight.
The first three were biracial,
one was by my grandmother.
And two was by another
woman, Allison.
And the other five was by the
Chinese bride who he married,
Ho Swee Yin.
The whole point of what was
happening in the Caribbean,
which was people mixed.
In the United States,
there were Chinese men
who were lynched for
mixing with white women,
or thinking they would.
And they pretty much got
their point across early.
So instead, who
did the Chinese men
mix with, because they weren't
able to bring their wives
and families?
Latinas.
A lot of Mexicans.
You hear in Latino culture,
people referred to as Chino.
Nicknamed Chino.
A good number of Chinese
mixed with Mexicans.
Native Americans.
Oh, and African Americans.
Throughout California, we've had
generations of different races
mixing with Chinese.
And a lot of people
are like, what?
So among the things
that I try to do,
is have this
conversation out loud.
Because what we're seeing
happening these days is,
the changing of this country
demographically in ways
that for some people It's just
happening, and for other people
it's quite alarming.
I'm not even to talk about
the politics of today.
I will not.
I'm going to stay
away from that.
But I want you to understand
that there's an expectation
that the way
California looks today,
or the big cities in California,
LA and San Francisco,
is what the entire
country is going to look
like in the next 25 years.
And for some of
us, it's like, yay.
Why?
Because I guess maybe contrary
to how my mother's grandmother
treated her, I find
that these days,
when you come when you're
in a mixed race environment,
and there is love involved,
and children are produced,
it's kind of hard
for the grandparents
to reject the child.
I don't usually
see that happening.
I usually see the grandparents
embrace and love the baby,
because love is love.
I bring all this up
because, notice how much
I've been talking about race?
I bring all this up
because, I'll bet you
all don't often talk
about race across lines.
And when I ran the news
department for NBC in New York,
I was Assistant News Director.
I was the number two person
in the news department,
before I eventually
became the boss.
But when I first entered
the news department,
there was an event going on.
The Central Park Jogger case.
Have you heard of that?
And simultaneously,
there was a case
going on where two young
African American men,
they were driving along
the highway in New York,
going to JFK.
Leaving from JFK airport,
and their car broke down.
And so they pulled off
onto the side of the road.
It was before there
was cell phones.
And they walked into
the neighborhood.
Because they were looking for
a payphone, to get a tow truck.
And they walked into a
neighborhood that wasn't
welcoming to young black men.
So this group of white
teens chased them down.
They ran them down.
The young black men ran
back onto the highway
to get to their car, and
while running, one of them
fell, and was hit
by a car and killed.
So that young man's
name was Yusef Hawkins.
I don't know if you
are aware of that one.
So simultaneously, we
had Central Park Jogger,
we had Yusef Hawkins.
I had been in the news
room for maybe three weeks
as Assistant News Director.
And at the time, I was very
disturbed about the language
that was being used to
describe these events.
So I got the scripts for
the six o'clock and the 11
o'clock newscasts.
And I redacted the names
of who had written what.
What reporter, what anchor,
what producer, nobody knew who.
I made copies of
them, and I gathered
those communities of people,
and I said here, read these.
So I'm new, and they're
like, Oh god, oh god, what?
I said, no, just read them.
We're going to talk about it.
Oh, god.
So we're reading, OK, what.
And I said, well,
I'd just like for you
to notice that in
some of the scripts,
people are referred
to as pack of wolves.
Some people are referred
to as committing
something called wilding.
And in some of the
stories, they're
just referred to as
a gang of youths.
Now, what I note is that
the descriptions that
deal with people in beast
terms, and animalistic terms,
refer to the Central
Park Jogger case.
And the gang of youths
are the white kids,
who chase down two black
teens who just were
looking to call a tow truck.
Why are we doing that?
And they were mortified.
Mortified, because with
no intent to be racist,
and to use racist
language and terms,
that's exactly
what was happening.
Oh you can bet that
people weren't slouching
in their seats after that.
And what I had said was,
the absolute worst time
to have discussions
around race, is
when a racist incident occurs.
Because if you're not
familiar with the language,
if you're not sensitive to how
people are going to take things
like, that is not your mama.
Well I was 9, 10, yeah I'm
going to punch you in your face.
But as now I'm an adult,
there's gotta be another way
of handling it, right?
There's gotta be another
way of handling it.
Right?
So what I used to do when I ran
the news department in New York
is, I deliberately
would have conversations
around race every day.
When nothing was-- And people
learned how to be respectful.
And discuss race and culture.
The multiculturalism
of this country,
and the increasing demographic
changes in this country.
More in the direction
of people of color.
Really does require that
although we are colleagues,
and some of us are
even friends, there
may come a moment
where it's tested.
And if you've never ever had
that conversation, in a non
racially explosive circumstance,
it could get a little sticky.
When I was talking with
Laura, I said well maybe
you guys should have
weekly-- somebody just
sit in the what's
it, Charlie's Cafe?
I got it right!
And do brown bag lun--
Oh wait, you guys
don't have to pay for lunch.
You don't need
brown bag lunches.
What am I talking about?
And have people-- Because
in this room, listening in,
everybody has at
least one story.
And I don't mean that it
has to be some scary story.
But you actually are
working with people who you
think you know reasonably well.
And how many of us are
really sharing who we are?
How many of us are really
talking about our culture,
and our background?
How many of us are
actually sharing?
You know I'll go into the
thing about black women,
because I'm that.
One of the things that
black women frequently
get tagged with, is, well,
you know, she's kinda harsh.
She's tough.
And I like to call her Sapphire.
What?
And when I worked at GE, and
we had a women's ERG group,
which was massive.
And we had one that
was for blacks.
But we had one for everybody.
But the one that I
talked about Sapphire in,
was the one that when I brought
just the black women together.
And how many of
them, I asked, were
told that they had
attitude problems?
You need to tone that down some.
I would tell people,
I would tell women.
I would tell black women.
Make up something.
What do you mean?
Say you went to listen to
some jazz over the weekend.
So you went to a soccer game.
OK, you didn't.
But you can't follow the adage
that we've all been told.
Don't be telling
people your business.
Because all of us have been
told-- See, she's laughing.
All of us have been
told by our mothers,
and our grandmothers,
and aunties,
don't be telling these
people your business.
Don't tell them-- Well when you
don't, you're not opening up.
You're not-- How do you
get to be on the team,
if you don't tell
some of your business?
I told none of my business.
I made up stuff.
Yeah I walked down to Central
Park Summer Stage this weekend,
it was great.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't see you
there, were you there?
Oh yeah, I was at
the early show.
Because you have
to give something.
I can't be telling-- I'm
still living in Harlem,
and-- well, let
me leave it alone.
What I'm saying is
that, and I hope
you're following where
I'm going with this.
It's important, it
really is important,
particularly for
those of you who
are working in this new
frontier, Google land.
You Googlers.
It's a brand new
frontier for you.
If we called you pioneers, I
would put it in the context of,
then don't do the
same old stupid stuff
that people were doing before.
This is an opportunity.
I just learned, you don't have
to do your own dry cleaning,
you ain't got to pay for lunch.
You all get driven to work
in some big white bus.
I'm like, you know this
is not the real world.
And given all of
that opportunity
to use your whatever,
for whatever,
maybe one of the things
that can happen is you
can foster-- Be on the
cutting edge of fostering
a better level of interaction.
Greater quality of,
whether it's camaraderie,
or actual friendship.
OK.
One last anecdote, and
then I'll take a question.
My last anecdote is, when
I was a new newspaper
reporter, reasonably new.
I was sitting at my desk,
and the hot shot reporters,
all of whom were white males,
were standing near my desk.
And I'm writing
whatever I'm writing.
And they're sitting
there chatting.
And one of them said, yeah, it
was like a Chinese fire drill.
Caught my ear.
I'm like, oh?
What is that?
So, inquisitive person
that I am, I said,
hey, what's a
Chinese fire drill?
Oh you know what a
Chinese fire drill is.
No actually I don't.
Oh that's like when you
were in high school,
and you were driving
a car-- I said,
I grew up in Harlem on welfare.
It would not be driving a car.
No.
It's the subway and the bus.
So I don't know what
you're talking about.
It's oh, you pull up to a light.
It's like the car is
full, like four people.
Everybody opens the
doors at a red light,
everyone runs around the
car, and they get back in.
And why is that a
Chinese fire drill?
And literally, the guy says,
oh you know, Chinese people.
Ching chong bong, long.
You know, who could understand
what it-- It's confusion.
At which point, I stood
up to my full height.
And I became 11 years old again.
I didn't hit him.
But I said, if you say
that around me again, I'm
going to you up.
That's me against four
white guys, right?
Four guys.
And it's me, and I'm new.
They looked at me, and I said,
because here's what I know.
What I know is, that
when I'm not present,
the slur you're going
to use is going to be
about people who look like me.
So my advice to you
is, don't do it at all.
At which point, I sat back down.
I said, oh by the way, my
grandfather was Chinese.
They're like, oh god, whatever.
It's important.
It really is important
in this day and age
that race, gender, culture,
nationality, all the above
is taken into account in a
variety of social environments.
And you all spend more
time with each other
than you spend with
people you love,
unless you love
somebody at work.
Which could be a little dicey.
So I would only suggest
that what you think about,
particularly because you
do have the opportunity
to come together in various
groupings and settings,
to talk about how to get
past and over this hump.
And make it a more meaningful
social interaction.
Questions?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If anybody does have a
question, and I hope you do,
there's a microphone there
that you have to talk into,
so that the people out
there in the disembodied out
there can hear what
the question is.
ANNE: Hi there.
Thanks for coming.
PAULA MADISON: Thank you.
ANNE: And as a Greek American
woman from Philadelphia,
I can resonate with some of
the things you were saying,
about being called
a little harsh,
a little this, a little that.
So thank you for those comments.
PAULA MADISON: Sure.
ANNE: So my question for you.
I've also lived through
the '90s, right.
And the '90s, I think of that
as a time when people were
aware of the language they
used, but what resulted
was the era of PC.
Which I personally
wasn't a fan of.
Because we were all
being so careful,
that everyone was
afraid to talk.
And I don't really have
any interest in that.
So I agree that
dialogue is important,
and I agree that we have
to talk about these things.
And I loved the point
you made about having
the conversation in
a non heated moment,
because I think
that's not something
I've thought about before.
And I think that's
incredibly useful.
How do we do that
without ending up
with people who are
maybe a little less
comfortable with that
conversation then feeling
like they can't speak at
all, which ruins the point?
PAULA MADISON: Right.
Great question.
Tell me your name?
ANNE: I'm Anne.
PAULA MADISON: Anne.
Thank you for that.
When I was 51, I started
running marathons.
I know, because I'm crazy.
And I didn't know you could
train to run a marathon.
I was like, oh, a coach!
Really!
I know how to run.
Like, you just run!
No, no, no.
It's a different
kind of running.
So my husband, who
by then had already
run like 9 or 10 marathons,
is like, baby listen.
He said, I've only ever
seen you run for the train.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, and?
He said, do you know
how long a marathon is?
I said 26.2 miles.
I know how long it is.
He said, well, maybe you
should start with a 5k.
I said, are you trying
to discourage me?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And I said, what's a k?
[LAUGHTER]
Truly.
That's true conversation.
So I had a running partner.
Who, lovely woman, one of
my dearest friends now.
And she's probably 10,
12 years older than me.
And she's Jewish.
And while running, we talked
about all kinds of things.
It's really hard to be
really mad at somebody
when today is a 12 mile run.
You understand?
You figure out
whether it's quilting,
whether it's playing
Minecraft, whatever
it is that's the common
bond, and then you
get beyond the superficial.
Yeah we talked about cookies,
and grandchildren of course.
But there would
be points where we
got into some really meaningful,
serious, and potentially
dangerous discussions.
But we had enough trust in each
other to know that this is not
cocktail party banter.
And she is one of my
dearest, and closest friends.
It's hard not to be
friends with somebody
who you're sweating on.
Well, I think.
But anyway, you get my--
it can't be sitting across
from each other at work, where
we both have a bottle of water,
and I want to talk
to you about-- that's
too- it's too focused.
It's too whatever.
And in an environment
like this, quite honestly,
the best way to have
these conversations
is to have them moderated.
Or brokered.
Have somebody who
really does know
how to encourage the
discussion, and can
tell when it may be
getting-- So talk about what
you meant by that, as opposed
to, what did you mean by that?
You know?
Yeah.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So that was a
really interesting point.
And you're talking about
having a moderator in a group.
But how can you kind of
organically facilitate that?
Because my assumption, and this
I guess, is a generalization,
is that the people
who are already
somewhat interested
in that already,
are the ones who attend.
Right?
And so we don't need
a homogeneous group
to consistently have
this conversation.
You kind of want to spread it
to the group that maybe doesn't
have any interest in attending.
So how do you have that
organically happen,
without forcing someone to go
to a round table or something?
PAULA MADISON: Right,
I don't believe you
can have it happen organically.
AUDIENCE: You cannot have it--
PAULA MADISON: I don't
think you can organically
have people say, today,
let's talk about scary issue
about-- I don't think that
organically, that can happen.
I think that it has
to be purposeful.
I think that there has
to be a decision made,
somewhere along the line.
Whether it comes out of
HR, whether it comes out
of a management group, whether
it comes out of somewhere.
But somebody who
says, look, this
is my first time at Google.
The only person I know
at Google is Laura.
And maybe some of you now.
But if this is an
environment where
you get your clothes cleaned,
you get your laundry done.
I don't even know what
else you all get for free.
[LAUGHTER] But if
it's designed to
enrich-- if it's designed
to smooth and tamp down
distractions, so you can have
an enriched, more effective
and efficient
experience here, look
at what you're not discussing.
Look at what is not
being discussed at all.
And how much more risk, and
it is risky, no question.
When I was at NBC Universal,
we brought everybody together,
on something called
NBC Unity Day.
And we dealt with a
lot of these things,
with the blessing
and the encouragement
of the tip-top most management.
Because you can't just make
this up, and say, so now,
every Wednesday we're
going to gather.
Because without it
being moderated,
it could get real dicey.
So the premise of organic, I
don't think it can be organic.
Not at work.
MAR JAYE: I actually have
an alternative there.
My name's Mar Jaye.
Thank you so much for
coming Miss Madison, that
was an incredible lecture.
But we do have a Group here
that was created organically,
in some way, called
Equality Working Group.
So if you go to your
internal Google Group,
and look that alias up,
we have monthly lunches.
Where people of all
types from Google,
we come together and have lunch.
And it's really
great, because you're
engaging with people who you
would probably never talk to.
Because a lot of us, we
silo ourselves in every way,
with people who look like us, or
talk like us, or think like us.
So it's a really cool
way for different people
to get together, to engage.
And we talk a lot about
race, and gender issues,
and things like that.
I mean people ask questions.
They're like, well why does
a black person feel this way?
They just don't
know, and they need
some help to kind of
understand and walk
through someone else's
shoes to understand that.
And so we put ourselves in this
really safe environment, where
we can do this here at Google.
So I would encourage you guys
to look up the Working Group
and come have lunch.
PAULA MADISON: I
think that's great
if you all have been
able to come together,
and pretty much-- maybe, I
don't know what the word-- but
leave any kind of
hostility that could
come from that at the door.
My experience is that, it
can get there really quickly,
if not.
But if what you all have done
is create that environment,
I applaud you.
Because that's spectacular.
That's a rare thing to happen.
So maybe free lunches and free
cleaning does make you nicer.
[LAUGHTER]
MAR JAYE: Yeah.
And I think the
great thing here is
that, like you were saying,
how do we bring people?
Because you're right, people
come who are naturally,
they want to engage in this way.
But there's a lot of people
who probably don't come,
because they're in
exact opposite feeling.
So we encourage everyone
to bring somebody
you know, who would
never come to this,
If you weren't their friend,
and encourage them to.
PAULA MADISON: You should
be applauded for that.
I don't know if you all have
like in-house communications.
Tell me how much
more time we have?
I don't know if you have
in-house communications,
but maybe you can let people
know that that happens.
Because that, I think,
is a game changer.
Having worked in so many places,
and in so many different roles
throughout my life.
What I have found
is that, it's tough.
It's real, and people, it gets
sometimes stuck right here.
Oh, so I do have
one more anecdote.
And again, I'm sorry all my
anecdotes involve violence.
I apologize.
[LAUGHTER]
When I was in college,
which was many moons ago,
there was a an African American
student, and a white student.
And they both lived in
the same dorm, both women.
And the white student said
to the African American--
and they were in the
bathroom-- and she
said, can I touch your hair?
And the black student said no.
And the white student said, no,
but I just want to touch it.
And the black student
said, don't touch my hair.
She actually was trimming
her afro at the time.
The white student reached
out, and touched her hair.
And the black student
stabbed her in the hand.
Right?
So what I'm getting
at is, what may
be comfortable for some people,
like-- So with my friend,
my marathon partner, we would
have conversations about stuff,
and I'd say, you know
can't be just talking
to every black person
about this, right?
You've got to go slowly.
But don't be walking
up to people who
you barely know, and say hey!
Because it could go very wrong.
So that's what I'm saying.
You all have created
an environment
in your group, where
there are ground rules.
And there are people around
who could serve as referees,
and moderators, who
are inside the group.
Because somehow you all
have come to an agreement,
that this is how we're all
going to conduct ourselves.
Which I applaud you for.
I think that's spectacular.
MAR JAYE: Thanks.
And I did want to give
one more anecdote,
because I think it's
something that--
PAULA MADISON: Does
yours involve violence?
MAR JAYE: It involves
racism in the workplace.
I had an experience.
I work in advertising
here at Google,
and I talk on the phone
with companies a lot.
And marketing reps, and things.
I was confused for,
I guess the person
I was talking to thought
I was a white person.
And this happened twice, in
my five years here at Google.
And they started to
say something racist.
What the first call was, about
Muslims, and then the other one
was about black people.
They assuming I was white.
So I really encourage people
to be allies to all races,
because that was the
first time in my life
I was able to actually
fight and support
a minority, being a minority.
That doesn't happen to me.
But in this unique situation, I
had the power to actually say,
well that's not right.
Because here they are,
thinking I'm white.
And so when you are
speaking with your peers,
you have a lot more power
to change the narrative
than you do when you are usually
the one that's disenfranchised.
Because a lot of times it goes
out one ear, and out the other
when you're the person
being disenfranchised,
speaking about your situation.
So I really encourage allies of
everyone to really speak out.
Because it actually gets
through deeper than I think
it might otherwise.
PAULA MADISON: And
I have a question.
Did you tell-- In
the situation where
it was something, racist
towards black people,
did you tell the
person you were black?
MAR JAYE: No.
I didn't.
Because he felt bad when
I actually was speaking
in support of black people.
So it took for him.
He was like, oh
well, I guess maybe
I didn't think of
it in that way.
PAULA MADISON: So
you think you think
it was more effective for
him to think you were white.
MAR JAYE: Yeah I think it
was more effective for him
to continue to
think I was white.
And then my manager told me
to never talk to him again.
[LAUGHING]
PAULA MADISON: That's
tough when you're
doing business with people.
I mean sometimes, you
don't have that option.
But I appreciate it.
Well thank you very much.
Thank you for that.
So that actually was
the last question.
I should tell you that, so
I'll be back there in a minute
if you are interested in
the book, which is very
multilayered and multifaceted.
And by the way, at the very
end of it, we went to China
and 300 of my grandfather's
direct descendants
welcomed the 20 of us black
Chinese into the family.
We have a long documented
legacy in my family
on the Chinese side.
I'm actually the 151st
generation of the Lowe clan.
And my family's documented
history goes back to 1,006 B.C.
And yet, on my
African Jamaican side,
I can't find documents
past grandparents.
But having said all
that, I would just
like for you to understand,
that while I talked
about my documented lineage,
my undocumented lineage
goes back farther than that.
Because the first man
and woman were African.
In fact, so we all came
from that continent.
So I just like to put into
perspective that while, oh yay,
I can look up the people in
my family for many, many years
back in our zupu, but the start
of mankind began in Africa.
So with that, I
thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you, Laura,
for inviting me.
My little intern grew up!
Yay!